elle durera huit ans deux fois plus
longtemps que la guerre mondiale
elle fit tomber si président du conseil
et se fonderait la quatrième république
elle ramena de gaulle au pouvoir puis
failli causer sa chute par deux fois
elle porte à la guerre civile en france
ces graffitis aujourd'hui encore
forcément
et pourtant la france en sortie plus
riche et plus puissante qu'elle ne
l'avait été depuis longtemps
elle fut bien évidemment à l'origine de
la nouvelle algérie
elle causa la mort de plus d'un million
de musulmans et l'exil d'un nombre
équivalent de colons européens terreur
impitoyable cruauté monstrueuse torture
systématique violence aveugle furent ses
caractéristiques dans les deux camps
ce fut aussi une époque héroïque et
tragique la dernière est peut être la
plus significative des guerres
coloniales la guerre d'algérie
favoriser la nouvelle débandade artois
la
[Musique]
cathédrale
ah
bravo les jeunes
[Musique]
1930 et colons européens célèbre le
centième anniversaire de la conquête de
l'algérie par la france persuadé d'être
encore là pour un autre siècle
[Musique]
personne ne voyait rien d'étrange au
fait que c'était les algériens eux-mêmes
les algériens musulmans les algériens
conquis qui fournissait le spectacle
[Musique]
car l'algérie a connu bien des
occupations les ruines romaines comme
ici celle de 2001 on en trouve un peu
partout dans la plaine côtière avant les
romains il y avait eu pendant plusieurs
siècles les soldats de carthage et aux
romains avaient succédé les byzantins
puis aux byzantins les vandales aux
vandales les arabes aux arabes les
espagnols et finalement aux espagnols
les turcs
[Musique]
au début du 19e siècle des pirates basé
en algérie paralysé le commerce en
méditerranée s'attirant la fureur des
autres nations parmi elles la france qui
convoitait depuis longtemps l'afrique du
nord étaient particulièrement motivés
napoléon déjà avait envisagé d'inclure
l'algérie dans son empire mais ce fut un
de ses successeurs qui on trouve à
l'occasion en 1827 le gouverneur d'alger
au cours d'une querelle frappe à
l'ambassadeur du roi charles vi d'un
coup d'éventail trois ans plus tard une
force expéditionnaire française
débarquer
à vrai dire le dernier des bourbons
chercher à distraire une opinion
publique de plus en plus hostile après
quelques semaines c'était la chute
d'alger à la même époque c'était à paris
celle de charles tisseyre la conquête se
traînait encore une vingtaine d'années
jusqu'à ce qu'en décembre 1848 l'algérie
soit unilatéralement incorporé à la
france nos comme colonies mais en tant
que partie intégrante de la nation à
l'égal de la normandie ou de la lorraine
et ce serait pour l'avenir le départ de
bien des problèmes cela signifie en tout
cas de la route de l'algérie était
ouverte à la convoitise des colons de la
métropole
mais le français moyen montré peu
d'enthousiasmé pour cette nouvelle
province et l'armée fut contrainte de la
peuplée avec les revues de la france
chômeur opposants politiques
indésirables vanilla et quand cette
source ce fut épuisé on chercha à
l'étranger en espagne à malte en italie
comme le disait un français nous avons
chassé les arabes pour les remplacer par
des italiens et des espagnols
ce ne fut qu'après la perte de l'alsace
et la lorraine lors de la guerre de 1870
qu'arrive à un large flux de réfugiés
ils furent bientôt 200 mille colons en
1940 il serait plus d'un million mais
les algériens musulmans seraient eux 10
millions
[Musique]
je
et
la plupart de ces musulmans vivaient
dans les quartiers les plus pauvres des
villes comme ici la casbah le vieux
quartier tueur d'alger conséquence de
l'apparition de la médecine occidentale
le taux de naissance des musulmans au
midd a grimpé doublant leur nombre tous
les 20 ans résultat les conditions de
vie dans les villes qu'on pire est
ailleurs les européens confisquer les
meilleures terres souvent sous le
prétexte que le propriétaire arabe était
un rebelle
bientôt apparurent de beaux quartiers
réservés aux seuls européens
durant ce qu elle appela pudiquement sa
pacification l'armée française anne il a
complètement la classe moyenne
algérienne qui leur est apparue qu'au
début de ce siècle avec les premiers
instituteurs et les premiers employés
musulmans la formation française et ceci
dès le début réclamait au pas
l'indépendance mais l'intégration car si
les musulmans d'algérie était de
naissance sujet de la france il n'en
était pas citoyens pour cela ils
devaient trahir leur religion certains
deux filles et prospérèrent sous le
sobriquet de béni oui oui
de leur côté les français comme tous les
colons du monde était persuadé que les
indigènes ne pouvait être
qu'irrémédiablement paresseux et
naturellement mauvais fait seulement
pour les tâches les plus serviles et ne
comprenant que la manière forte toute
idée de réforme était tout simplement
ignorés
aux musulmans les terres pauvres aux
colons les beaux domaines
domaine obtenu souvent grâce à des prêts
avantageux du gouvernement est exploité
grâce à l'argent des contribuables en
métropole
[Musique]
les trappistes avait importé la vigne en
algérie à temps pour que les colons les
pieds noirs comme ont commencé à les
appeler profitent de l'épidémie de
phylloxéra qui ravagea le vignoble
français vers 1880 l'algérie devint
bientôt un important producteur de vin
en plus de la vigne les subsides de
l'état encouragé les colons à cultiver
les céréales surtout le froment plus
tard la luzerne les légumes et surtout
les agrumes oranges et citrons
ajoutèrent à la richesse
[Musique]
en dehors des mines peu d'industries il
fallait maintenir l'algérie indépendante
de la france on extrayait surtout du
plomb et du fer ainsi qu'un peu de
charbon
ce que la france apporte à de mieux à
l'algérie ce fut sa culture mais
l'éducation n'était pas répandue
également un enfant musulman avait douze
fois moins de chances d'aller à l'école
ou qu'un enfant européen
le chômage est élevé pour les musulmans
et ceux qui travaillaient était mal pays
la solution immigrés en france
métropolitaine en 1920 il y était soumis
en 1950 un demi million leur salaire
soutenait des familles entières parfois
tout un village
[Musique]
pour les colons cependant la vie était
confortable et il comptait bien qu'elle
le reste
avant l'algérie était un pays et est un
département français qui était une
province paisible où les français les
pieds noirs vivent est vraiment bonne
coopération avec les arabes et il y
avait évidemment des propriétaires
agriculteurs en majeure partie chez les
français mais il y en avait beaucoup
aussi chez les arabes tout ça se passait
très bien il y avait une coopération qui
était très bonne li les arabes vivaient
dans un climat très serein et avec
vraiment pas d'hostilité vis-à-vis des
pieds noirs le travail se faisait
aussi bien chez les propriétaires entre
arabes et français que chez les
propriétaires entre français et arabe
dans les affaires aussi bien industriels
qu'agricole la collaboration était total
il n'y avait pas d'animosité
le fait était quand même que évidemment
la proportion en arabe était supérieur à
proportion de français ce qu'ils
menaient si vous voulez dans certaines
circonstances
plus de délinquants du côté arabe que du
côté français un vu l'importance de la
population et ce qui a créé un petit
climat quand même mais simplement au
niveau de la délinquance et au niveau
au
niveau 2
des problèmes qui se posaient dans les
villes mais à la campagne tout se
passait très bien nous qui vivront en
ville nous subissions -7 7 déc station
ces vexations comme ceux de la campagne
par exemple on été
mélangés avec les autres ici il y avait
une ségrégation raciale le cinéma il y
avait quand même on ne permettait pas de
rentrer dans
la partie si vous voulez
dans des plages quand on était dans des
plages on nous isoler parfois on met en
prison parce que on a osé côtoyer les
européens enfin on à mon compte en
colonisant pays c'est devenir l'esclave
de deux dominateurs
les riches souffraient moins de cette
situation que les porcs les gens
instruits
souffraient moins que les gens n'ont est
lui donc il ya si vous voulez à la
veille de l'insurrection de 54 il y
avait tout de même une certaine
différence
diversification
est ce qui me concerne
ce dont j'ai souffert
pour la première fois peut-être c'est
dans l'armée j'ai été mobilisé
en 1943
j'étais censé
aller libérer la france et le monde de
la peste noire
dans l'armée
j'ai tout de suite
constaté des différences entre algériens
et français
pour l'armée française
leemans arrière-pays algériens c'était
le bled pour les soldats les
administrateurs les colons eux mêmes il
exerçait une véritable fascination comme
on disait alors l'algérie vous monte à
la tête
[Musique]
près de cinq fois la france 70 fana
belgique s'étendant sur une distance
égale à celle qui sépare bruxelles de
gibraltar l'algérie était un pays est
dur
[Musique]
non
avec ses ciels immenses et ses espaces
infinis composé pour ces neuf dixièmes
de désert l'algérie était pour
jusqu'à ce que de ce sable stérile
surgissent le pétrole
[Musique]
mais si ces paysages étaient variés que
dire de ses habitants arabes kabyles
berbères chaouia touareg les moeurs et
de couleurs différentes
parlant des langues absolument
étrangères mais unis par la religion
ces différences données arguments aux
français pour nier l'existence d'une
nation algérienne pour beaucoup les
algériens paraissait son est secret
obstiné et intransigeant certes ils sont
moins ouverts que leurs voisins
marocains tunisiens cela dit leur
courtoisie est grande leur dignité et
plein de réserve
[Musique]
les femmes qui ont joué un si grand rôle
dans la révolution se sont vus promettre
l'émancipation une promesse qui n'a été
que trop rarement tenues
les algériens ne vivent pas uniquement
dans des oasis où des villages de
montagne ils ne passent pas leur temps à
dos de chameau ou à vendre des dates et
à bavarder autour d'un pays c'est en
fait un peuple de citadins et alger est
une des villes les mieux situés du monde
il n'est pas facile de fixer le moment
exact où l'idée d'une nation algérienne
commença à se former dans l'esprit les
algériens elle a sans doute été toujours
dans l'est elle fut conserver vivante
par les chefs religieux par les
enseignants les intellectuels qui ont
trouvé l'expression dans leur conflit
avec les français mais ceux ci étaient
habiles à opposer une ethnie à l'autre
joints des différences de race et de
langues les nationalistes resté divisé
leur mouvement fragmenté proie facile
pour le pouvoir redoute et des pieds
noirs
là
[Musique]
mais la fin de la deuxième guerre
mondiale fut aussi celle de la
suprématie de l'européen donc d'écolo
déjà la défaite humiliante de la france
en 1940 avec un grand impact auprès des
algériens sensible à la gloire et au
courage les nationalistes étaient
convaincus qu'avec l'aide des
anglo-américains leur heure avait sonné
a donné comme un coup de fouet et
encourager le mouvement et la pousser à
renforcer ses revendications
la guerre la défaite de la france
le débarquement allié en algérie ont
encouragé ce mouvement nationaliste
modéré
au courage et souvent nationalistes
modérés et vous savez comment les
colonialistes ont répondu par les
massacres de 1945 à sétif guelma
coeur
des français
[Musique]
pour l'écolo cette répression avait
brisé les reins du mouvement
nationaliste une fois de plus fragmenté
en faction rivale les pieds noirs
étaient convaincus que cette révolte
était le résultat des quelques réformes
qu'on leur avait imposé dans l'euphorie
de la fin de la guerre
d'autre part il était clair que paris
avait d'autres problèmes il fallait
reconstruire le pays
a été solennellement d'installer le
ministre gouverneur général monsieur
naegelen a lui même ouvert la première
session de cette assemblée on y va quand
l'ampleur du chemin parcouru et la
grandeur de la tâche qui attend les
représentants de l'algérie
[Musique]
pour la nouvelle génération de
nationalistes algériens dont beaucoup
avaient combattu dans les rangs des
alliés et y avaient été traités en égaux
ce ne serait pas par des élections
qu'ils arriveraient à leur but il en
faudrait arracher leur liberté
peu importe le prix déjà beaucoup se
tourner vers les techniques de la
révolution marxiste
les colons eux n'avaient pas changé de
sentiments
les pieds noirs ou
à 8,7
cette
année
le forum
les français d'algérie sont arrivées en
juillet 1830 et pour la plupart d'entre
nous nous avions des familles qui
remontait à l'époque de la conquête de
l'algérie et au fil des générations ce
sentiment de de pérennité dans cette
terre française d'algérie s'est
installée dans l'esprit dans le coeur de
tous les français d'algérie donc nous
sommes bien entendu passionner pour ce
qui ne pouvait être que notre terre
natale
j'ai cru que l'algérie qui n'avait
jamais été une nation et qui ne restera
peut-être pas longtemps une nation
indépendante
étaient liés à la terre de france et au
peuple français
par des liens
qui aurait pu évoluer dans leur
structure juridique mais qui ne devait
pas être corrompu et aujourd'hui encore
je considère que ceux qui ont rompu ses
liens
étaient pour les algériens des
inconscients ou des aveugles et du côté
français
des inconscients ou des traîtres
l'image que le monde se faisait de
l'algérie étaient bien différents la
légion les méharistes des fortes à du
désert des fantasias la danse du ventre
les femmes voilées ce n'était pas
seulement une vision hollywoodienne
c'était aussi celle de paris peut parler
du fonctionnaire du ministère de la
guerre boulevard saint germain se
demandaient pourquoi les musulmans ne
devenait presque jamais officié
[Musique]
pour l'armée l'algérie était un immense
champ de manoeuvre ou se préparer à un
combat qu'on sentait venir et qui serait
mené selon les règles de la dernière
guerre
[Musique]
mais les règles du combat serait bien
différente et ce ne serait pas les
politiciens à bari i les établir et il
est vrai qu'ils avaient d'autres
problèmes
et tout d'abord survivent
de 1945 à 1954 en neuf ans la france
avait connu vingt gouvernement certains
pour quelques semaines bien peu
dépassant les quelques mois
coalition copinage combine alliance
aussitôt rompue ce petit ballet était la
risée du monde entier mais dans ce petit
jeu le vote des représentants de
l'algérie étaient souvent décisif est
obtenue en échange du blocage des
réformes
et puis l'algérie n'était pas le seul
problème colonial de la france
concernant la rampe
de
la guerre qui ravage l'indochine dure
depuis plus de sept ans mais il aura
fallu la défaite de dien bien phu pour
que le monde comprenne qu'il s'agit de
bien plus que d'une guerre
d'escarmouches qu'il s'agit d'une guerre
totale
la guerre d'indochine avait coûté à la
france un dixième de son budget annuel
et la vie d'un tiers des jeunes
officiers sortis de ces académies au
total près de cent mille hommes étaient
morts dans cette lutte sans compter les
mutiler les blessés ni les souffrances
des malheureux ados chinois
cela ne pouvait plus durer mais paris
balancé entre un désir de paix et un
désir de victoire militaire l'hésitation
était la règle ce dont profitait un
adversaire de la france au chili
[Musique]
la défaite de dien bien phu au nord du
vietnam en mai 1954 fut presque un
soulagement et bien entendu le
gouvernement tombe à
une nouvelle figure émerge à du monde
politique pierre mendès france qui a
entrepris de négocier la fin des combats
à la surprise générale il y parvint dans
les délais qu'il s'était fixé
et ainsi en ce mois de septembre 1954
pour la première fois depuis 1939 la
france connaissait la paix hélas un
nouveau problème pointé à l'horizon
et lorsque je passe rapidement en 54 au
nom des accords de genève nous avons dû
abandonner
la de chine
c'est la honte au coeur que nous l'avons
fait car nous avons abandonné les
populations qui s'étaient engagés à nos
côtés et qui après notre départ
ont été massacrés j'ai vu de mes yeux
avant bien avant l'ère des boat people
se jeter à la mer pour rejoindre le
bateau qui quittent et indochine et
particulièrement le vietnam
nous sommes dans que et nous avons donc
été engagées en algérie
rage au coeur et la honte au coeur
d'avoir été obligé
d'abandonner les populations que nous
avions engagés et qui à cause de notre
départ avait été massacrée
développement
pour contrer far away from new york en
france sur le
mois 24 et gloucester
à gastes pour
mes fautes en 17 ans
le monde arabe est très sensible aux
événements extérieurs et je vous
rappelle que les versets du coran disent
que toute force vient de dieu et notre
échec à dien bien phû a été très
ressenti et j'ai senti un flottement et
une volonté de ses loyers nous chez la
population musulmane les femmes qui
allaitent au marché était accueillie
avec une certaine agressivité
en 1954 la sous-préfecture de gens de le
planquer comprenez l'aurès les plus
hautes montagnes de l'algérie une région
sauvage hostile que même les romains
n'était jamais parvenu à occuper
[Musique]
les français s'étaient contentés de
garnison autour du massif assurant la
protection de la voie de chemin de fer
et des quelques routes par une série de
fortes un certain inoccupés
[Musique]
depuis des siècles l'orece servait de
refuge aux hors la loi cet automne la
gent de le plan ne disposait pour
maintenir l'ordre que d'une poignée de
gendarmes pourtant depuis l'été la
région fourmiller de nationalistes
persuadés que leur heure allait sonner
au départ divisés sur les objectifs à
poursuivre et sur les méthodes pour y
arriver il avait pu au cours de réunions
clandestines réaliser une série
d'accords il avait d'abord choisi un nom
le front de libération nationale le fln
puis une date pour déclencher leur
révolte le 1er novembre jour de la
toussaint jour férié pour les
pieds-noirs et enfin le lieu de leurs
attaques la gorge désertique de
tighanimine au coeur des aurès
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le but du fln était d'isoler les aurès
et d'en faire leur place forte espérant
ainsi que leurs compatriotes se
soulèveraient en masse mais le premier
jour fut un fiasco presque totale une
accumulation d'erreurs ce qui poussait
les autorités à sous-estimer l'événement
mendès france compte par
le ministre intérieur qui était monsieur
francesco mitron actuellement président
de la république française est venue le
3 novembre
c'est à dire trois jours après
l'insurrection
pour voir quelles étaient les mesures
qui avaient été prises et d'apprécier et
donné des consignes justement pour
poursuivre le combat puisqu'il
considérait il l'a dit d'ailleurs à ce
moment là que l'algérie c'était la
france et il y a eu des moyens
considérables qui ont été mises à notre
disposition
la visite de mitterrand relever le moral
des pieds-noirs et l'armée d'algérie
avait plus besoin de renforts que
d'hommes politiques car sur les soixante
mille hommes qu'elle comptait 3000
seulement étaient aptes au combat
ce fut le conte lança dans les aurès
avec mission de trouver l'ennemi et de
le détruire mais l'ennemi refusal combat
du moins selon les règles et ni les
tanks ni les troupes transportés ne
purent le dénicher les mulets aurait
mieux convenu mais nous on en manquait
et il n'y avait qu'un seul hélicoptère
pour toute l'algérie les généraux et la
plupart des officiers ignorait tout de
la guérilla
en dépit de quelques succès initiaux et
de la capture de bandes fln qui contre
toute prudence s'étaient déplacés deux
jours les attentats et les embuscades
devenu chose courante et la crainte
gagner peu à peu les troupes françaises
généralement inexpérimentés les
musulmans loyau étaient souvent
assassinés aux abords mêmes des
garnisons
les français étaient toujours en retard
d'un événement sur le fln dont les
hommes connaissaient le moindre repli de
terrain le moindre buisson et qui le
jour restait introuvable
comme l'interrogatoire des populations
donné peu de résultats les autorités
élargir le champ de leur arrestation
mettant sous les verrous quiconque leur
paraissaient suspects se basant sur des
listes établies depuis des années et
souvent inexactes bien souvent les
interroger ans avait aussi peu sur
l'insurrection que les interrogateurs
mais leurs protestations d'innocence ne
servait à rien après quelques
interrogatoires musclés le fln
trouvaient parmi eux ses meilleures
recrues un certain fernand qui allait
devenir fréquent en algérie
et français voulait avant tout rétablir
l'ordre ensuite seulement étudierait ton
les exigences nationaliste mais sans
réforme la rébellion continuerait la
quadrature du cercle dans toute sa
splendeur
les enterrements firent bientôt partie
intégrante de la vie quotidienne en
algérie aucune communauté y échapper la
violence du fln visaient aussi bien les
musulmans
surtout ceux appartenant à des groupes
nationalistes rivaux aux collaborateurs
des français postiers gardes-champêtres
petit fonctionnaire était réservé un
sort particulièrement cruel ce que les
français à plaire le sourire kabyle la
gorge tranchée d'une oreille à l'autre
[Musique]
tandis que la tension monte en afrique
du nord la france armes ses partisans
parmi les volontaires on retrouve nombre
de vétéran des deux guerres le préfet de
rani promet personnellement les armures
recrues qui chaque jour se présente par
centaines
[Musique]
les généraux français devaient se
contenter des troupes déjà sur place car
paris le refuser tout renfort à
l'exception de vingt mille hommes et de
20 compagnies de crs les pieds noirs ne
marquait aucun enthousiasme pour
s'enrouler tous les prétextes leur
étaient bons pour échapper à la
conscription
aussi incroyable que cela paraisse ce
fut la majorité musulmane qui dû
défendre la minorité européenne et le
moindre paradoxe de cette guerre et
qu'elle se déroule à entre musulmans la
plupart du temps l'armée française en
compte a plus que le fln et ses unités
musulmane furent parmi les meilleurs
étant du pays elle le connaissait et
surtout connaissait les méthodes de
leurs adversaires ce que les officiers
français mirent du temps à fait
en attendant à paris pierre
mendès-france avait nommé gouverneur
général d'algérie jacques soustelle au
langage ferme mais à l'esprit libéral il
avait dirigé les services secrets de
gaulle pendant la guerre et était député
gaulliste depuis quatre ans l'accueil
des pieds-noirs fut circonspect et la
chute de mendès-france avec l'aide du
lobby algérois ne fit pas pour l'été
mais soustelle répéta que l'algérie
devait rester française très vite
cependant il allait parler d'intégration
[Musique]
et oise d enter
les saisies et me jean cn ça tout est
situé chez luigi adnoc truite the day
before
beccu zouhir had to ensure date de tout
comme unité ou lève tout cas d'heure en
ce qui nous concerne et mon j'ai été
personnellement président les mouvements
lycéens d'algérie nous pensions qu'il y
avait en algérie de profondes réformes
offraient à faire parce qu'il y avait
une discrimination entre les deux
communautés et que les français
musulmans devaient bénéficier davantage
considérable qui n'était pas le cas ce
qui n'était pas le cas dans l'algérie
d'avant 1954 le statut de l'algérie
avait été mise en place en 1947 et
devait permettre à ces réformes qui
avait élaboré sous cette sous 700
algérienne de arriver à une certaine
égalité entre les communautés et
malheureusement il ya eu un certain
nombre de blocages qui ont été effectués
par ce que je pourrais appeler les
représentants de la grande colonisation
car il faut se rappeler que les français
d'algérie sont ils commettent une
communauté composée de 90 % de gens de
condition modeste aux moyennes et qu'il
y a une petite oligarchie de quelques
centaines de grosses familles qui
détiennent les pouvoirs de décision sur
le plan économique sur le plan politique
et sur le plan de l'information les
grands journaux d'algérie sont la
possession des grandes familles qui
bloque tout système d'évolution parce
qu'ils craignent de ils craignent la
perte de leurs prérogatives et de leur
puissance politique et il est évident
qu'il fallait ébranlé cet état de
rapports entre les communautés
c'est avec la création des sas les
sections administratives spéciales que
jacques soustelle espérait ébranlé cet
état de rapports entre les deux
communautés surtout dans les régions qui
voyait rarement le visage de l'autorité
française
recrutés principalement dans l'armée les
képis bleus étaient plus de 400
possédant chacun au moins une des
langues indigènes des lieutenants et des
capitaines plus diplomate que tacticien
leur tâche montrer les bons côtés de
l'autorité française leur méthode
rencontrer les gens recueillir leurs
doléances de première main et à porter
remède le plus vite possible en fait des
assistants sociaux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les sas furent un succès indéniable une
des rares lueurs dans cette guerre
d'algérie chaque jour plus ont admiré
par la plupart des indigènes parfois
même aimé il était redoutée par le fln
pour leur sens politique les pertes
furent élevés dans leurs rangs ils
étaient des cibles faciles
parallèlement soustelle doubla le nombre
des constructions scolaires supprima
quelques unes des injustices les plus
flagrantes du système électoral
répondent-ils usage de l'arabe dans
l'administration lança une campagne de
travaux publics pour diminuer le chômage
une tâche gigantesque
bien souvent qualifié de politique du
trop peu et trop tard
viewed as was in first ep i would grave
compliquée qualité complète access de
maastricht ou all franck chaîne publique
france 3 tous parlemente en soi
afterweb venture
franco
algérien bottes des odeurs un terry 13
enafrique
[Musique]
mais les sabotages du fln maintenait la
tension entre les deux communautés et
rendait l'exercice d'un gouvernement
équitable difficile le fait que ces
sabotages durer encore après six mois
l'impressionnait la masse musulmane la
soi-disant massification et la notion de
responsabilité collective se retourner
contre l'armée la première sens et
regagner la confiance des indigènes
dégénérait souvent en une répression
brutale paris ordonna de modérer cette
répression mais quelle modération
attendre de jeunes soldats qui ont vu
tomber leurs camarades dans une
embuscade la responsabilité collective
était encore plus discutable qui rendait
responsable de tout dommage causé à une
propriété française le village le plus
proche c'était le moyen le plus sûr
d'accroître une influence du fln de plus
pour beaucoup ces méthodes de rappeler
trop celle des ss
l'armée avait bien peu de défenseurs
[Musique]
you can't fight et guéret la
with conventional means
and always goes to say you can't you
have not you say sledge amar tou qui les
fly
sometimes des
offices afin de charmer ou avoir de
refroidissement mais minds
but the great man of law is pis pour un
swing big and rich à un jogging times un
symbole aux mines des
fifteen ont pointé guerrila giné
district à de left foot
mais le fln aussi avait ses problèmes au
début les pertes avaient été lourde et
le recrutement l'an la masse musulmane
attendant de voir comment les choses
tourneraient avant de s'engager les
armes étaient rares la révolte avait
débuté avec en tout 3000 400 fusils
dépareillé et quelques mitrailleuses les
armes datant de la guerre
le réapprovisionnement ne pouvait venir
que des français pillage des dépôts vols
dans les casernes armes prises sur les
soldats tués
elle était de 1955 le fln décida
d'intensifier son terrorisme espérant
ainsi provoquer une répression plus dur
en traînant par contrecoup les modérés
et rendant tout compromis impossible
une tactique classique de la guérilla
l'endroit choisi pour cette nouvelle
escalade le port de philippeville
le véritable tournant c'était en août
lors de la révolte du constantinois un
matin
des masses d'hommes et de femmes
mallarmé fanatisés se sont rués sur les
villes villages et post français et on
procédait de véritable massacre
aussitôt après
j'accompagnais jacques soustelle sur les
lieux
c'était vraiment horrible en du sucre ev
des femmes éventrées des gosses brisé
frappé contre des murs
l'armée a riposté
c'était le début de la guerre de la
véritable guerre d'algérie
pendant ces midi le bo guerre mais c'est
là le véritable guerre une guerre
impitoyable et malheureusement durable
c'est ma 5e d'un côté et des réactions
inévitable qui ont eu lieu ont provoqué
plusieurs
milliers de morts on parle de 8000 et
ces événements ont beaucoup touché la
france
des images des funérailles des européens
égorgé à philippeville uran immense
impact en france comme le fln l'avaient
espéré elle affectait aussi l'attitude
des responsables en algérie bien que
jacques soustelle s'en défende
plus aux joueurs quand ils mènent les
bêtes wind fabouré n ai pas aimé
d'extensive tout obstruant de cadres et
haim est ménée mais
n'empêche les gosses including
l'imaginent ferhat abbas un choix d'un
sofa
foot my finger at inc pound men cause
sauf de trois beaux
shows date windows
massacre souplesse force et ne
[Musique]
de tout ça sauf ille et vilaine où le
jouet ni un philippeville
littman to me that we had cour le 10
terminé made in my eyes deux has been
taken cheikh
ahmar
[Musique]
je pense que les événements du 20 août
furent du point de vue militaire parce
que là un des tournants de la guerre
ce jour là la preuve a été faite que la
population soutenait le fln les gens se
ruaient les mains nues pour arracher les
armes dans les dépôts de l'armée
française et les données ou fln
doazit mois
cette union des masses et du fln fut le
tournant de la révolution
dans la boîte à
gifles et
jean marie rausch à bien la reliera
attaque cadenas ou de m au fil des ans
ces massacres marqué le début du cycle
infernal désormais tout musulman était
un assassin potentiel pour les européens
tout européen une menace pour les
musulmans
pour des raisons de politique intérieure
le gouvernement qui avait succédé à
mendès-france provoqua des élections
générales en janvier 1956 il les perd 10
lamentablement conséquence le gouverneur
général en algérie dû être remplacé
à l'annoncé du rappel du gouverneur
général jacques soustelle et de son
remplacement par le général catroux
l'agitation gagne toute l'algérie
soixante mille personnes manifestent
leur soutien jacques soustelle reste à
l'occasion de son départ pour échapper à
leur enthousiasme
c'est dans un blindé qui gagne le port
et c'est par un exercice d'équilibriste
qu'il termine son embarquement
le rôle de soustelle dans la guerre
d'algérie n'était pas fini un rôle
souvent controversées
[Musique]
l'accueil réservé lors de sa visite à
alger au nouveau président du conseil
monsieur dit molette est
particulièrement ajouté des milliers de
colons se rassemblent autour du monument
aux morts où monsieur molette loi déposé
une couronne en quelques minutes la
manifestation tourne à l'émeute une des
plus violentes et connu l'algérie
la colère de la foule était dirigée
contre le successeur annoncé de jacques
soustelle général catroux mais en son
absence c'est contre l'homme qu'il avait
nommé le président mollet au plus tôt
contre sa malheureuse couronne mortuaire
que la foule se déchaîna on allait bien
voir qui était maître en algérie
et quand le soir même du mollet 2004 où
ce fut du délire la foule l'avait prouvé
sa force une force capable un jour de
faire tomber un gouvernement de faire
même tomber une république comme le fln
les pieds noirs avaient compris les
avantages de la violence
[Applaudissements]
la visite de guy mollet alger
effectivement
le 6 février 1956 me paraît être l'une
des dates les plus importantes avec le
13 mai 1958 de l'histoire de france
contemporaine
mes amis et moi même nous revendiquons
l'entière responsabilité de cette
journée à plus d'un titre historique et
même si vous voulez des tomates jeté à
la face des ministres qui étaient alors
présents
melet annonça également que le nombre
des soldats remet algérie monterait à
plus d'un demi million 10 fois plus
qu'en 1954 la guerre d'algérie entrée
dans une phase nouvelle et dangereuse
la journée du 6 février à acculer guy
mollet le gouvernement le régime a une
sorte de capitulation
alger ce jour là à gagner est la
quatrième république été condamné ou à
sauver l'algérie ou à mourir comme elle
n'a pas pu gagner la guerre d'algérie
elle est tombée
[Musique]